[Music]
so Marvel have pretty firmly thrown down
the Infinity Gauntlet excuse the pun and
claim December as their month with the
release of both the Captain Marvel and
Avengers trailer in the same week like
I'm sure most of you did when I heard
the news I immediately loaded up the
trailer and watched it no phones no
distractions no terrible YouTube reviews
and whilst I was pleasantly surprised I
wasn't as blown away as I hope to be now
before you hit the thumbs down button
just bear with me this is a very somber
trailer that I feel works at setting up
things rather than teasing climaxes and
conclusions it's clear from the outset
that Tony is in a pretty tight spot and
the rest of the world is grieving what
is most heartbreaking for Tony is that
he has absolutely no clue whether pepper
is alive or not and I love the whole
Robinson Crusoe aesthetic that they've
gone for here obviously Captain Marvel
will probably come and rescue him before
the dreaded oxygen runs out but this
still is beautifully teasing of just how
devastating Danis was I love the tease
of Danis on the planet as well with his
shad gauntlet and his armor and the
Scarecrow Stan is just it's a great
easter egg that if you read the Infinity
Gauntlet saga then you know exactly
which comic that's from when Captain
America narrates you really get the
feeling that they are completely broken
and that they don't really have the
fight in them to return this is why the
reveal of Hawkeye as the Ronin is so
important as it definitely highlights
that he has lost his family in this had
to return Steve and Black Widow state
that this is going to work and I love
the way that the a symbol comes back
together which of course symbolizes the
Reformation of the Avengers which will
no doubt happen in the film the ending
highlight of Ant Man 2 is a perfect note
to end on even if it does spoil the
cliffhanger at the end of Batman and the
wasp so overall I did have a lot of fun
with the trailer but it felt a bit
smaller scale and I was expecting but
hey it's still a great trailer even if I
enjoyed Captain Marvel slightly more so
what are your thoughts on the new
Avengers trailer and what did you prefer
out of it and Captain Marvel comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of into the spider
verse which will be linked
the end of this one it's got all the
spoilers you need including the whole
movie and post-credit see this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]